en esta copa aumenta el lobby de las
Industrias de los combustibles fósiles
636 personas están registradas este año
es decir un 25% más que lo que hubo en
la cop 26 de Glasgow según los datos de
global witness y lo preocupante es que
no solo vienen en nombre de las
compañías sino también como delegaciones
de 29 países global witness Afirma
además que todos los datos provienen de
las listas oficiales de la ONU por lo
que dicen que el lobby se está haciendo
a plena luz del día Hay un gran número
de lobistas de los fósiles que sí tienen
acceso privilegiado a las conversaciones
climáticas de la ONU porque vienen como
miembros de delegaciones nacionales El
ceo de bp vino como parte de la
delegación de mauritania lo que le da
acceso a la negociación
no es un espacio en el que la acción
climática esté al frente del proceso es
un espacio donde tuvimos lo que la gente
llama un día gas y petróleo y es Claro
que los combustibles fósiles tuvieron
acceso privilegiado a las que no
tuvieron las ongs
la presidencia de la Cope responde que
las Industrias están para rendir cuentas
pero los activistas creen lo contrario
pues afirman que esto reduce sus
espacios
por eso al día de la descarbonización